the movie starts with a narration from a
guy named ben he mentions that he is
going to reveal the biggest most
well-hidden secret in all of human
civilization every night after people
brush their teeth get under the covers
and finally fall asleep a different
version of them comes to life they are
the sleepwalkers they venture out in the
streets and live the best version of
themselves without any fear or worry
sleepwalkers are aware of their waking
selves that they carry out during the
day but the waking selves are oblivious
to the sleepwalkers moreover if the
secret of the sleepwalkers is ever out
that is if normal people find out about
them they will mentally die this means
that the sleepwalking personality of a
person will eventually vanish in new
york city the protagonist ben wakes up
in his apartment he is also a
sleepwalker an alternate personality
that only comes out after his other self
goes to bed shortly after ben leaves for
work in the subway he comes across a
woman alison who smiles at him gently
however ben doesn't recognize her and
simply leaves that evening ben arrives
at his apartment and watches television
while eating some pasta after dinner he
falls asleep and not long before
midnight sleepwalker ben wakes up this
ben lives a life free of consequence and
responsibility just the way he likes it
sleepwalker ben readies to venture into
the nightlife as usual so he dresses up
takes out his camera from a hidden box
and goes outside in the street he meets
a fellow sleepwalker trey who asks ben
how his waking or daylight was shortly
after ben and trey are joined by two
other guys danny and flynn the group
wants to do something adventurous and
lively for the night so they attempt to
paint graffiti on a public wall ben
videotapes their notorious act but
suddenly a police car arrives and chases
them away later the group arrives at a
diner which also happens to be alison's
workplace turns out that she is friends
with the boys so she greets them while
serving coffee and pancakes ben and
alison flirt for a while before the
latter mentions that she saw him the
other day realizing that she simply saw
his other self he lies that he was too
caught up in work and didn't notice her
seeing this trey and the boys warn ben
to not get involved with a waking girl
as it could destroy his life however ben
doesn't listen to them and secretly
manages to get alison's number as the
group continues dining they get a
notification on their watches this warns
them that it's time for their other self
to wake up hence they hurry back to
their apartments and tuck themselves
into bed at six a.m in the morning ben
wakes up like a normal person oblivious
to the adventures his other self enjoyed
last night at work his boss calls him
and mentions that he hadn't been
considered for a position that he had
applied for previously as expected ben
is distraught but he decides to keep
working so that one day the superiors
will notice his hard work and reward him
later that night sleepwalking ben is
furious for getting rejected at work so
he instigates a fight in a bar when he
gets knocked out by a stranger he wakes
up to his normal personality for a split
second ben is shocked to find himself in
a bar with random strangers but danny
quickly knocks him out again this time
sleepwalking ben wakes up outside the
bar trey convinces sleepwalking ben to
not get involved in any fights since
normal ben will end up in a hospital
unsure of what happened to him it will
also cause him brain damage trey then
suggests ben leave for the night and
take some rest but sleepwalking ben
hasn't had enough fun so he goes to the
diner to meet allison the two have
dinner and talk about their lives and
families sadly their romantic
conversation is interrupted when
sleepwalking ben gets the notification
to return home before leaving alison
expresses her desire to have another
date with ben the following night and
the latter gladly agrees the following
night sleepwalking ben goes to his
ex-girlfriend kate's place for some
dating advice kate is also a sleepwalker
initially she lashes out at ben for
coming to her for such a matter but she
eventually settles down ben reveals that
he likes alison but since she is awaking
girl he doesn't know how to handle the
situation kate warns him that he is
risking his life for awaken girl as his
sleepwalking discovery could cost his
life despite this ben insists on some
advice and kate finally starts helping
him she mentions that if he really likes
this girl he has to be cautious about
everything he needs to plan dates treat
her like normal people and lie to her
about his day job all this time he has
to be equally alert about his other self
sleepwalking ben takes kate's advice and
goes to meet allison for their second
date night the two stroll around central
park before they come across a large
view stone allison wants ben to go there
so the pair climb up the stone and watch
the city lights then the two talk about
their work life and alison mentions that
she always wanted to be a musician she
came to new york hoping a friend would
set her up for a recording but she was
deceived for the last three years she
has been waiting tables and living an
ordinary waitress life in turn ben also
reveals that he wanted to be a sea
explorer ever since he was a child in
this way the pair have fun getting to
know each other until the crack of dawn
after this ben accompanies alison to her
apartment and the two share a sweet kiss
before parting one night trey and the
other boys become worried as ben has
been ignoring them for a week now trey
calls ben who is busy having dinner with
allison on the phone ben doesn't mention
his relationship and simply tells his
friend that he is sick alison is also
unaware that ben hasn't talked about
their relationship with his friends in
the following scene a worried tray goes
to kate's apartment to ask about ben
although reluctant at first kate reveals
that ben was there a few days ago
seeking advice for dating a waking girl
hearing this trey becomes furious and he
scolds kate for supporting his
delusional friend the following day at
work normal ben is called upon by his
boss who informs him that she has
reconsidered his application for the
promotion he will get an interview call
the next morning from the ceo himself
this excites ben and he happily exits
the room later that evening ben readies
his suit for the interview while going
through his closet he discovers
sleepwalking ben's hidden box and the
video camera but he doesn't find
anything suspicious
except for you know the hidden box and
the video camera at midnight
sleepwalking ben wakes up and
immediately hides the contents of his
box in the kitchen later he and allison
go for a stroll in the park there she
surprises ben with a cute setup for a
date night where she plays her favorite
music and the two dance together after
dawn ben accompanies alison to her
apartment and at the same time he gets a
notification that his time is up however
instead of rushing back home he decides
to spend more time with alison the two
have coitus and after alison falls
asleep ben leaves a note and sneaks out
of the room sadly due to sleepwalking
ben's carelessness normal ben wakes up
late and misses his interview he
immediately hurries to his boss's office
to apologize for oversleeping and pleads
to reschedule for the interview but to
no avail later one of ben's colleagues
randall asks ben if he wants to join him
for a beer after work and the latter
agrees on the other hand trey visits
allison at the diner and tries to force
her to break up with ben when she
doesn't listen trey lies that ben isn't
who he claims to be as he is cheating on
her with other women however his efforts
are once again futile as an enraged
allison kicks him out of the diner now
with no other options left trey hires a
girl to approach ben and hook up with
him at the bar ben and randall share a
bottle of beer they share a bottle of
beer just then ben is approached by
trey's girl and they chat for a while by
now ben is already drunk so he makes out
with the girl the two then head out to
have a romantic dinner unfortunately the
girl leads ben to the same diner where
his girlfriend works when alison sees
ben with another girl she lashes out and
asks him why he is cheating on her sadly
normal ben who is also drunk doesn't
recognize her and he simply acts
confused this adds to allison's fury and
she storms out of the place heartbroken
back at his apartment once the normal
ben and the girl make love with each
other they fall asleep at midnight
sleepwalking ben wakes up and finds out
that alison mistook him for his other
personality he hurries to her apartment
but alison doesn't answer the following
night sleepwalking ben goes to the diner
where he apologizes to alison but she is
so disgusted at him for humiliating her
she also asserts that trey was right
about ben that he was in fact not the
person he seems to be realizing that
trey was behind all of this ben goes to
their local hangout bar and punches him
despite this trey tries to make his
friend understand that what he's doing
could cause his demise but an agitated
ben ignores him and walks away later
sleepwalking ben goes to kate's
apartment where she shares that her
other self is getting married her
sleepwalking self is also fading but she
doesn't know the exact reason kate
reveals that she has been going to bed
early and waking up late for the past
three weeks she notes that maybe it's
time for her sleepwalking self to fade
while the other personality lives her
life fully one day at the office normal
ben falls asleep after tiresome work and
not long after sleepwalking ben wakes up
in his place confused he ventures out
and notices allison heading to the park
with her guitar nervously he follows her
only to find out that it's not the
normal alison it turns out that allison
is also a sleepwalker but she changes
her sleepwalking personality during the
day unlike ben and his friends as the
two talk sleepwalking alison realizes
that her normal self has fallen in love
with sleepwalking bed the latter asks
for a solution and allison simply
suggests that he move on later that
night sleepwalking ben goes back to
kate's apartment only to discover that
sleepwalking kate has now faded he
realizes that kate is finally happy with
her normal self so her other personality
has died this gives sleepwalking ben an
idea since he cannot reveal the truth to
alison and also cannot stop thinking of
her he decides to kill his personality
hence he goes to his friends and shares
his plan although the boys are taken
aback they support ben's decision and
hug him one last time before parting
ways back in his apartment ben writes a
to-do list which includes three main
priorities to quit his boring job to
sign up for scuba diving and lastly to
watch a sunset in central park following
the list at first he calls his workplace
and informs his boss that he is quitting
then he calls an agency and signs up for
scuba diving lessons in the next scene
normal alison wakes up in her apartment
and finds a video desk that says play me
curious she puts it on and sees
sleepwalking ben this time he reveals
everything to her in the video
sleepwalking ben narrates about
sleepwalkers he mentions that
sleepwalkers are people with different
personalities who share the same body as
their normal self they venture out at
night and live their life to the fullest
without any fear or consequences they
know what their normal selves are doing
but always try to respect their
boundaries the biggest secret about the
sleepwalkers is that if they are
discovered by the normal people they are
killed forever after this ben shares
that it's time for him to let go of his
sleepwalking self since he doesn't want
to live that life anymore as the video
goes on sleepwalking alison suddenly
appears and starts playing the guitar
the sight of her doppelganger shocks
normal alison and she finally believes
ben at the end of the video ben asks one
last favor from alison to go to central
park and wait for his normal self to
arrive shortly after normal ben wakes up
in his apartment and by this time his
other self has already died as ben gets
ready for his day he comes across the
to-do list confused he calls his work
only to find out that he has already
quit his job as expected this shocks ben
but he eventually assumes that he did it
himself he then decides to follow the
final task on the list to watch sunset
at the park on reaching he sees allison
who is also her normal self watching the
sunset since ben doesn't recognize her
well he tries to walk away but alison
invites him to join her the movie ends
as the pair enjoy the lovely dusk
overlooking the city that was the most
complex metaphor for getting blackout
drunk that i've ever seen subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching